[Wren] There's no audio so we gotta reset up
all of that. So a while back I saw a video
on Instagram of this guy riding on a
one-wheel on top of two cases of beer,
just riding along and I thought you know
what I'm going to do that with these peach boxes.
-What did you call them?
-Pen Pineapple apple box
The trick is to land on it from up here...
[Nick] You need to go this way a little bit
So you want me to not... cause as soon as this
apple box hits the sensor it's gonna... [Wren] yeah
I'm gonna friking break something
[Nick] *Laughs* You good?
Alright, this apple box is touching the wheel
you want me to slide it over?
[Wren] Oh my god this is the worst idea.
It's not even activated...oh there it is.
[CMike] Go to your desk.
[Wren] No no, the sensor keeps turning off.
Make sure it's like, right on the center between the two pads.
[Nick] Good?
[Wren] God I should be wearing a helmet.
This is so dumb.
[CMike] Wren, are you afraid?
[Wren] Yeah, I am significantly afraid right now.
[CMike] Just go to your desk, go to Obie.
*Sights*
Ok, as much stability as you can.
This is good.
OK, this this good. [Jake]You're like a, like when a toddler rides a...
[Wren] This is
[Jake] How you going to get down?
[Nick] You're doing it Wren!
[CMike] You're doing it Wren!
[Wren] OK, how do I get off?
[Jake] Nice
[Wren] Thanks for the help. Oh my god that was so scary.
I can feel how unstable that was.
[Jake] That was actually pretty legit. I thought you were going to crack your head.
It's like when... so I go to these motorcycles, like, get togethers,
and at all this things there is always someone who is doing wheelies
and it's kinda like that
You're just watching the whole time and they're doing a wheelie down the street
and they land and you go 'That was actually really cool'
But the whole time you are just waiting for something to go horribly wrong.
Something really cool is happening as you are watching this video.
Carmichael and I are out in Salt Lake city,
at Sundance film festival and we have been asked to speak
on a brand panel.
We are going to be speaking in front of the some of the highest people
at some very very big corporations
about advertisement on YouTube.
There is going to be people on that panel such as:
The senior marketing director for a major shoe company,
the VP of branded entertainment for a major soda company,
and we are going to be talking to them directly about
the state of advertisement on YouTube.
If you have concerns, problems or issues about
anything with the current state of YouTube advertisement,
put a comment in this video and I will read it
directly to the people responsible for selling those ads.
I don't hear you typing.
We can't as a channel let this opportunity pass by
without informing you guys that this is happening.
People are going to be out there saying "Oh well, there shouldn't
be ads on YouTube" or "I just use ad block bro" or whatever.
But the fact of the matter is YouTube would not exist
if it wasn't for advertisement.
That is an absolute fact.
If you're not ok with that, then, there's nothing that can really be said for that.
But assuming you are like most other people,
you're gonna accept a certain level of advertisement
for the entertainment that you get on this platform.
Now...
lets do that better.
Pretty cool? Alright, lets do it.
[CMike] Don't hear any typing!
[Jake] I don't hear typing.
[Nick] You good?
[Wren] Alright.
[Nick] Hands off.
[Wren] Ok, this is a lot more stable.
[CMike] Tickle him!
[Wren] I can't stop it! I can't stop!
Hey, you did it!
[CMike] Hey Wren! That's a dollar.
[Wren] Oh no.
The way the one wheel works is that there is a sensor
like a pressure plate, and the box is too evenly distributed
to actually activate it.
So if I put something thin underneath the box that should work.
[CMike] Works!
Ah AH!
Wren that's a second dollar!
[Wren] I'm like a little Mario Turtle
Oh god oh oh no, no stop stop
[CMike] Hey Wren, that's a dollar
[Shonduras] We are about to skate a hoverboard
This is so heavy!